hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about a really cool topic and that is
how microbes can actually jump host
species and specifically looking at this
from the point of view of humans so when
new pathogens jump over to the human
species and infect them for the first
time so let's talk about how this
happens first you need to know that all
pathogens have a specific host sometimes
just one host sometimes a small set of
hosts that they infect and the hosts the
pathogen is capable of infecting is
known as its host range now sometimes a
pathogen can actually jump from a host
that it's been infecting for many
generations into a brand new host
species and this is accomplished by
mutation so when the pathogen whether
it's a virus or a bacterium or a fungus
when its genetic material mutates
sometimes that allows them to be able to
infect a cell in a host that they
previously were not able to infect and
so that's a result of that random
mutation process and there are a lot of
diseases that you've heard of that have
actually done this in the past things
like smallpox measles HIV bubonic plague
scarlet fever these are all pathogens
that once upon a time or actually what
we call zoonotic diseases
so so not adores o o Nanak sometimes
we'll hear that pronunciation just means
that they infect animal species other
than humans and so all of these used to
be sinaitic diseases but now at some
point in human history they jumped over
into the human species and now they're
major human pathogens and so this is
actually an example of speciation
following habitation of a novel
environmental niche and all that means a
novel environmental niche just means
that there was an ancestral pathogen
that could not infect humans at some
point it mutated and was able to infect
humans and so it was able to jump into
the human species that new host was the
new niche and then you actually get two
species of pathogen one that's capable
of infecting the new species and then
the one that's capable of infecting the
old species so as an example there is
render pest and measles I'm sure you've
heard of measles which infects humans
but the most closely related pathogen to
measles is actually render pest
which is a closely related pathogen that
infects cattle Buffalo and a few other
types of animals and so once upon a time
thousands of years ago there was a
common viral ancestor that was infecting
cattle and then cattle were domesticated
humans were living in close contact with
cattle and then at some point right
about here on this diagram this pathogen
actually jumped in to humans for the
first time and after that there was this
divergence where there was one strain of
the
pathogen that could still infect the
cattle that was the render passed virus
and then there was a strain that could
infect humans and that's the measles
virus by comparing the genetic material
of sort of modern-day viruses render
pests has actually been eradicated now
but of the last known render pests
viruses with modern diesel Cyrus's
scientists can look at how many
differences there are between those two
viruses and can look at the estimated
mutation rate of this virus and can
actually estimate about when this jump
occurred when this jump into the human
species occurred and it was roughly a
thousand years ago and so we know that
this happens were able to trace it to
use molecular clock techniques to even
estimate approximately when it happened
now let's talk about the process now
it's got four steps I'm summarizing
these from the book Guns Germs and Steel
by Jared Diamond which was published I
believe in 1997 but these are the steps
through which a pathogen that is a
zoonotic pathogens in duck takes on
animal species makes the transition into
infecting humans Easy's and so first the
first kind of step in that process is a
pathogen that can transfer from animal
to human only rarely so sometimes a
human can be infected but there's no
human-to-human spread and even the human
infection doesn't happen very often
because that pathogen is still much more
adapted to their current host species
and isn't doing very well in the human
host so an example of this would be like
tularemia which is also known as rabbit
fever the next step is when the pathogen
actually mutates to the point where it
can enter into one human host and then
it can spread from human to human but it
dies out rather quickly an example of
this would be in the late
1950s there was a virus called the old
yum-yum virus I think I'm spelling that
correctly on yungyeong virus and it
caused an epidemic and it was kind of
initially a little scary but then it
died out so it entered a population in a
spread from person to person several
people got sick but that was the end of
it and it was no longer part of it was
no longer causing human infections step
three in this process is when an
infection actually becomes established
in humans so not only can it transfer
from human to human but it's doing so on
a fairly regular basis it's not
something that dies out quickly so there
are people that would put Lyme disease
into this category there are also people
who would list the Zika virus in this
category because with both Lyme disease
and Zika people get them it's happening
a lot so it's established and humans but
hasn't become necessarily I'm a major
killer at humanity even though theif it
was pretty scary there for a couple of
years in South America for the most part
that epidemic has really died down there
aren't very many people showing Zika
infections anymore and so it's unclear
whether Zika is going to be something
that we're going to have to worry about
in the future and the final step of this
process is when you have a disease that
has become a major long established
epidemic disease confined to humans that
means no longer jumping from an animal
reservoir on occasion but a sort of
human to human transmission sometimes
by vectors like mosquitoes that have
been major diseases of humans that have
been causing disease in humans for a
long time so this would include things
like malaria tuberculosis I'm gonna
abbreviate that as TV chickenpox as well
as some of these ones we've already
talked about smallpox measles HIV play
scarlet fever and so these are all
examples of pathogens that have jumped
into humans and now the question really
remains is well what's gonna happen next
you know what's gonna be the next
pathogen that we have to deal with it's
going to be new to the human population
because it's jumped over into humans
from an animal these things are
happening on a fairly regular basis and
your HIV jumped into humans as recently
as with the late 1800s
and so certainly you know the next one
could be a major killer of humanity that
we haven't even discovered yet so
definitely something to keep in mind if
you want to watch any other videos then
you might be interested in some of my
videos on my epidemiology and disease
playlist also on my pathogen life cycles
playlist so things like germ theory and
the life cycle of hookworm and the life
cycle of schistosomiasis parasite so
definitely take a look at those and
thanks for watching biology professor